the 1700s in Europe are often referred
to as een Age of Enlightenment it was a
time we had come out of the Renaissance
we had rediscovered science and reason
and in the 1700s we saw that come about
with even more progress of society as we
exit the 1700s and enter into the 1800s
we start having the Industrial
Revolution and people saw the steady
march of human reason of human progress
and because of because of this a lot of
people were saying hey humanity could
we'll continue to improve and improve
forever to a point that poverty will go
away we will turn to this perfect
utopian civilization without Wars
without strife of any kind and there was
something to be said about that you had
significant improvements in fact you had
even more dramatic improvements once the
Industrial Revolution started but not
everyone in the late 1700s was as
optimistic and one of the more famous
not so optimistic people was Thomas
Malthus Thomas Malthus right over here
and I will just quote him directly this
is from his essay on the principle of
population the power of population is so
superior to the power of the earth to
produce subsistence for man that
premature death must in some shape or
other visit the human race very
uplifting the vices of mankind are
active and able ministers of
depopulation they are the precursors and
the great army of destruction and often
finish the dreadful work themselves but
should they fail in this war of
extermination sickly seasons epidemics
pestilence and plague advance in
terrible or inter in terrific array and
sweep off their thousands and tens of
thousands should success still be
incomplete gigantic inevitable famine
stocks in the rear and with one mighty
blow levels of population with the food
of the world so not not so uplifting of
a little quote right over here but this
was his general sense he lived in a time
where people were being very optimistic
that progress the march of progress
would consider would go on forever until
we got to some
open civilization but from thomas
malthus's point of view he felt that if
people could reproduce and increase the
population they will that there's no way
of stopping them so from his point of
view the way he saw it so let me on that
axis let's say that that is the
population population and this axis
right over here let's say that that is
time so by his thinking and everything
that he'd seen in reality up to that
point would would back this up but if
people had enough food and time they
would reproduce and they would reproduce
in numbers that would grow the
population so in his mind the population
would just keep on increasing it'll just
keep on increasing until it can't
support itself anymore until the actual
productivity of the land can't produce
enough calories to feed all of those
people so in his mind there would be
some natural upper bound based on the
actual amount of food that the earth
could support so let's say that this is
let me do that in a different color so
in his mind there was some upper bound
there was some upper bound and once you
get to that upper bound then all of a
sudden the vices of mankind will show up
and if those don't start killing people
then all of these other things will
epidemics pestilence plague and then and
then famine people are actually starving
to death
so in his mind once you got to this
level maybe you had a couple of good
crops people are feeling good about
themselves they overpopulate but then
all of a sudden you have a bad crop or
because you have a bad crop people start
fighting over resources and wars happen
or maybe the population is so dense that
a plague develops and then you have a
massive wave of depopulation and so you
would just oscillate around this limit
and this limit some people refer to as a
Malthusian limit but it's just really
the limit at which the the population
can sustain itself and from thomas
malthus's point of view he did recognize
that there were technological
improvements especially in things like
agriculture and that this and that this
line was moving up he had seen it in his
own life in his own lifetime that this
line had moved up but from his point of
view however far you move this line up
the population will always
xate forward and catch up to it and
eventually get to these Malthusian
eventually get to this limit and then
the same kind of not so positive things
that he talks about would actually
happen and some people now say Oh Thomas
Malthus he was so pessimistic he was
obviously wrong look at what's happened
we have so much food on this planet
right now we've gone through multiple
agricultural revolutions and they are
right in the last 200 years since
Malthus so since the early 1800s we
really have been able to outstrip
population so this line this line up
here has been moving up much faster than
even population so right now we actually
do have more calories per person on the
planet than we had we've had at any time
in history but it's not saying that
Thomas Malthus was wrong it's just
saying that he maybe he was just a
little bit he was he was a little bit
pessimistic and when that that limit
will be reached now the other dimension
where you might say that he was maybe
wrong was in this principle that a
population will increase if it can
increase if there is food and if there
is time people will reproduce and a good
counterpoint to that is what we've now
observed in modern developed nations and
soul is this right over here shows the
population growth I got this from the
World Bank but the population growth of
some modern developed nations and you
can see the United States is is pretty
low but it's still positive it's still
it's still well it's still over half a
percent but even that adds up when you
compound it but if you look over here
Japan and Germany and Japan and Germany
have less immigration than the United
States
if you especially Japan they are
actually negative so just this
population left to its own devices if
you especially if you account for people
not going across borders just the
population itself growing they actually
have negative growth so there's some
reason to believe that this is evidence
that Thomas Malthus was wrong he didn't
or not completely right he didn't put
into account that maybe once a society
becomes rich enough and educated enough
that they might not just populate the
world or have as many kids as they want
they might try to do other things with
their time whatever that might be so I
just wanted to expose
due to this idea time will tell if
thomas malthus if we can always keep
this line if we can always keep this
line of food productivity growing faster
than the population and time will tell
whether our populations can become I
guess we could say developed enough so
that they don't and execrable I can
never say that word
they don't always just keep growing
maybe they do become a Japan or a
germany situation in the world
population especially if if we have a
high rate of literacy eventually does
level off so that it never even has a
chance of hitting up against that
Malthusian limit but thought I would
introduce you to the idea and now you
can go to parties and you can talk about
things like like Malthusian limits and
if you want to know what country and you
know is maybe closest to the Malthusian
limit right now and we've talked about
this before but a good case example is
something like mahadesh they are right
now the most population density in the
world they have 900 people per square
kilometer and just to give you a sense
of perspective that's 30 times more
dense the United States is so if you
took every person in the United States
and turn them into 30 people in the
United States that would give you a
sense of how dense Bangladesh is and
it's probably due to a certain degree
that it's very fertile land it's the
River Delta of the Ganges essentially
makes up the entire country but they do
they've have in the past had famines
they've gotten a little bit beyond that
but still you do have major problems
with flooding and resources so hopefully
they'll be able to they'll be able to
stay ahead of the curve